on connaît tous des histoires
d'accomplissement qui ont déjoué les
pronostics
mais si je vous disais que personne
n'aurait misé un kopeck sur lénine
l'homme qui a fondé l'urss avant la
révolution russe de 1917 il était un
outsider dans le mouvement ouvrier
international
on le considérait comme un agité sans
pouvoir médiocre même en comparaison des
personnalités brillantes et
prestigieuses comme rosa luxembourg
et puis ses partisans les bolchéviks
était disqualifié comme une secte sans
avenir parce qu'ils étaient relativement
peu nombreux et que c'était surtout des
intellos qui passaient leur temps dans
les bibliothèques
or les mines et les bolchéviques ont
réussi à prendre le pouvoir
puis à édifier en seulement quatre ans
un état d'une puissance incomparable qui
durera jusqu'à la fin du xxème siècle de
cet exploit j'ai tiré sept principes à
partir de la lecture de la biographie de
lénine d'hélène carrère d'encausse et
vous allez voir que le 7e principe est
étonnant je suis romain et vous êtes sûr
mais l'idée de culture générale
[Musique]
l'énigme n'était pas un enfant de coeur
mais il n'était pas non plus un
mercenaire il avait un projet politique
qu'il avait largement promu avant la
révolution
un peu comme les hommes politiques qui
publie un livre quand ils sont en
campagne
[Musique]
de fait le fondateur de l'ue a assez
c'était un intellectuel
avocat de formation il lit beaucoup et
il diffuse ses idées en écrivant plein
d'articles
il a une forte aptitude à se battre sur
le terrain des idées à polémiquer par
écrit si bien qu'il sera toujours plus à
l'aise avec l'intelligentsia qu'avec les
ouvrir à peine 25 ans il crée aussi un
journal qu'il baptise très simplement le
journal ouvriers et il se prend
immédiatement un an de prison
mais surtout il obtient progressivement
sa propre tribune dans tous les journaux
à tendance révolutionnaire et il s'en
sert à la fois pour marteler ses propres
idées et attaquer frontalement celle de
ses adversaires
enfin à lénine a également écrit
plusieurs ouvrages théoriques dans
lesquelles il expose sa pensée politique
il y a notamment que faire où il défend
le rôle du parti politique pour répandre
le marxisme chez les travailleurs et
l'état et leur évolution dont vous
pouvez retrouver une synthèse sur le
site militer de culture générale il a
donc produit un travail théorique
conséquent mais il est paradoxalement
très critique à l'égard de ses
compagnons de route qui sont trop à
l'aise sur le terrain des idées et ne
semble pas prêt à passer aux actes
[Musique]
s'il avait vraiment un côté intellectuel
lemmings et donc aussi un dirigeant
pragmatique qui n'ignoraient pas à la
nécessité de la discipline c'était déjà
dans sa nature
il était un homme d'ordre prude fidèles
à l'éducation stricte qui l'avait reçu
au sein d'une famille bourgeoise unis à
la fin du xixème siècle
mais c'était surtout une dimension
fondamentale de son projet politique
en effet pour les mines le peuple ne
peut pas faire la révolution tout seul
il a besoin qu'une élite révolutionnaire
qu'il appelle l'avant-garde prennent la
direction de son destin pour le libérer
de ses chaînes
il faut en pratique une organisation
structurée de professionnels c'est le
parti l'édile l'imaginent à partir de
deux modèles lusine et l'armée le parti
doit donc être centralisées hiérarchisé
et autoritaire ils affirment eux mêmes
dans que faire que l'intérêt supérieur
du parti justifie de renoncer aux
principes démocratiques
ce pourquoi trotsky la traiter de
robespierre en puissance la discipline
de fer du parti vise également à créer
une unité idéologique qui proscrit les
théories hétérodoxes et qui soumet
complètement la vie intellectuelle à
l'organisation cette conception du parti
a fonctionné parce que les mines était
un chef d'envergure décidé au discours
clair impressionnant de force et de
volonté
les bolchéviks qui était très soudée
autour de lui
[Musique]
les lignes ne pouvait bien évidemment
pas faire la révolution avec ses seules
armes
ils avaient besoin d'un effet de levier
il n'a donc pas hésité à sacrifier la
moralité des moyens à la possibilité de
la réalisation pratique de son projet
politique et se fragmente isme s'est
manifesté assez tôt étonnamment le parti
bolchévique et ses journaux étaient
financées par de grands industriels par
des aristocrates et même par les états
unis après ces financiers étaient
certainement eu aussi pragmatique il
soutenait probablement les adversaires
de leurs adversaires mais le pragmatisme
de lénine est allé beaucoup plus loin au
point qu'il a immédiatement entaché sa
réputation et à plus long terme sa
légende
il y avait un allié très puissant
derrière lui et les bolchéviques
[Musique]
l'allemagne le calcul de l'allemagne
était simple en les aidant à propager
leur thèse en russie elle pourrait
réussir à moindre frais à économiser un
adversaire dans la première guerre
mondiale
dans les faits lénine a reçu de l'argent
et de l'aide de parvus un agent secret
allemand qui avait prévu une grève de
masse en russie depuis plusieurs années
il a notamment fourni un wagon et
d'importants crédits destinés à financer
la propagande pacifiste l'éolien des
bolchéviques ont donc été décuplée grâce
à ce puissant allié mais la limite de
cette stratégie comme je l'aï déjà dit
c'est que la réputation de lénine en a
pris un coup peu avant la révolution
d'octobre le gouvernement avait un
dossier complet contre lui et par chance
il n'est pas sorti en entier mais les
nombreuses fuites ont dégradé son image
et atteint le moral des bolchéviques
d'où la nécessité de contrôler les
médias
[Musique]
le premier principe pour fonder l'urss
je lui dis c'est de diffuser largement
ses idées mais ce n'est pas suffisant il
faut aller encore plus loin pour assurer
leur victoire c'est d'abord une question
de moyens financiers avec l'argent de
l'allemagne li ning dispose d'un
carburant sans commune mesure avec ceux
des autres partis dès son retour il
développe donc une presse sur un large
spectre afin de s'adresser à de
multiples catégories de la population
parfois assez précises comme les femmes
ou les militaires sur 41 journaux 14
soit plus d'un tiers ne sont pas en
russe mais en gérant rejet un arménien
lituanien letton etc
plus globalement le tirage total des
journaux du parti atteint 320 mille
exemplaires ce qui est énorme pour
l'époque et pour le pays et lénine et
les bolchéviques ne s'arrête pas aux
gens dans leurs simples emery produisent
aussi un nombre considérable de tracts
chaque jour tout cet effort de
propagande aurait bien sûr été
impossible à financer avec les seules
cotisations des militants
ensuite une fois le pouvoir conquis le
contrôle des médias est devenue une
question de moyens politiques toujours
très préoccupés par la discipline et de
idéologique les mines a rapidement fait
passer un décret limitant la liberté de
la presse contre-révolutionnaire ce qui
ad'ailleurs heurté beaucoup de ses
propres partisans
ensuite l'accumulation des difficultés a
rendu encore plus nécessaire l'unité
idéologique et la liberté de la presse
et celle de l'édition ont donc disparu
avec le communisme de guerre il ne
restait plus que la presse du parti et
les éditions d'étape dénommé goded stats
contrôler elle même les allocations de
papier les années avancent en les lignes
considéré finalement que la presse
devait être entièrement consacré à la
diffusion de l'idéologie communiste
au moins les choses étaient claires
[Musique]
et aller ou ne pas y aller c'est quand
le bon moment pour faire la révolution
il y avait déjà failli avoir une
révolution en 1905 mais la réaction du
gouvernement avait progressivement
étouffé le mouvement et les grèves en
1917 les bolchéviques avait également
hésiter plusieurs fois avant de
finalement s'emparer du pouvoir en
octobre
en juillet les knicks étaient même en
fuite près de la frontière finlandaise
quand le gouvernement provisoire a
demandé son arrestation parce qu'il
craignait d'être assassinée en prison a
priori ce n'était donc pas le moment est
pourtant le chef des bolchéviques leur
demande de s'immiscer dans tous les
organismes possible et de harceler le
gouvernement loin de l'action il
trépigne si bien qu'il rentre finalement
incognito il restera en permanence
déguisé avec une perruque blonde jusqu'à
la fin de la révolution
il est convaincu qu'il ne faut pas
attendre le soulèvement populaire c'est
à dire que les professionnels de la
révolution doit s'emparer de pouvoir ils
s'allient donc avec trotski pour
contourner la prudence de son propre
parti et enclencher le processus
révolutionnaire pour les lignes c'est le
moment ou jamais le kairos
on aurait aussi entendu dans sa bouche
la formule de napoléon on s'engage et
puis on voit le 25 octobre petrograd
l'actuel saint pétersbourg pas sous
l'autorité des bolchéviques sans
qu'aucun coup de feu ne soit y est
[Musique]
déjà ligne était lui même un homme
notoirement violents dont la grande
brutalité avait choqué pas mal
d'interlocuteurs en politique la
violence qu'il s'agisse de la violence
physique ou plus simplement de
l'arbitraire la violence au sens global
ne l'a jamais arrêté pour accomplir son
projet mais on ne peut pas dire qu'il ne
nous avait pas prévenus dans que faire
il y avait déjà clairement exposé la
nécessité de la violence révolutionnaire
et de la lutte armée pour assurer le
triomphe du prolétariat dans l'état et
la révolution c'est pareil la
bourgeoisie et l'état prennent vraiment
très cher soit sa plume il faut briser
détruire démoli à l'état en réponse à la
violence bourgeoise puisque l'état c'est
l'instrument de la répression du
prolétariat par la bourgeoisie et puis
bon la dictature du prolétariat et bien
c'est une dictature alors royaume des
bisounours
la pratique politique de lénine a été
plutôt fidèle à cette théorie comme
principaux trophées de chasse on peut
retenir dans l'ordre chronologique les
différentes phases d'épuration sein même
du parti bolchévique
bien sûr la prise du pouvoir en elle
même mais beaucoup plus à moscou qu'à
saint pétersbourg l'épuration à large
échelle de l'administration la
répression très violente des insurgés
les plus calmes pouvant espérer au mieux
finir dans des camps de concentration
l'envoi dans ces mêmes camps de tous les
éléments jugés douteux comme les prêtres
les soldats des militants adverses
les paysans réfractaires la répression
du clergé qui justifiera la liquidation
de près de 8000 serviteur de l'église
rien qu'en 1922 ou encore l'expulsion de
russie de tous les intellectuels
soupçonnée de sympathies
contre-révolutionnaire bref lénine
c'était pas la douceur incarnée
[Musique]
le voici enfin le septième principe si
croustillons je voulais à tout prix
partagé avec vous l'anecdote que j'ai
trouvé dans cette biographie et qui m'a
étonné mais je suis peut-être naïf par
jean bien au fait les lignes a dirigé
pendant pas mal d'années avant la
révolution le parti bolchévique or vous
imaginez bien que cette machine
politique de carbure pas aler non il
faut y injecter des roubles or le parti
bolchevik se portaient très bien
c'est une petite entreprise qui ne
connaissait pas la crise et connaissant
lénine sa violence son pragmatisme et
son ambition
on imagine mal vendre des meubles ou des
tee-shirts non sa source principale de
financement c'était les braquages et oui
les bolchéviques faisait comme font tous
les groupes qui veulent renverser
l'ordre établi
ils prennent par la force les caisses
sont facilement remplis par des attaques
à main armée rebaptisé expropriations
que les lignes justifie non pas en
invoquant l'intérêt général mais par la
perspective de la révolution c'est donc
la conscience tranquille que les
bolchéviques dont notamment staline
souvent dans les bons coups se
fournissent auprès des meilleurs
marchands d'armes pour exercer un
terrorisme systématiques contre les
forces de l'ordre les institutions et
surtout pragmatisme oblige les biens
expropriables mais ce n'est pas tout en
bon gestionnaire les bolchéviques se
sont diversifiées dans la captation
d'héritage et même dans le faux
monnayage scandalisé les mencheviks le
parti rival les accusé de trahir l'idéal
socialiste
mais contrairement à eux les lignes tht
est prêt à sacrifier la pureté de
l'idéal à sa réalisation pratique et
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il a réussi à
fonder l'urss
[Musique]
en conclusion les sept principes pour
fonder l'urss sont la diffusion de la
vision une discipline de fer au sein de
l'organisation
l'aide d'alliés puissant le contrôle des
médias le sens de l'opportunité
l'acceptation de la violence nécessaire
l indifférence à l'odeur de l'argent
alors bien sûr c'est une manière biaisée
et incomplète de résumer
l'accomplissement improbable que
représente la fondation de l'urss mais
je voulais tout particulièrement insisté
sur le grand pragmatisme de lénine à la
lecture de cette biographie
j'ai en effet l'impression que c'est
bien cette disposition à l'exécution
pure à l'action débarrassé de tout
scrupule conditionnée par la seule
opportunité qui a finalement rendu
possible ce dont personne ne l'aurait
cru capable
si vous avez aimé la vidéo donnez lui un
pouce bleus et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la
suivante pour lire l'article de blogs
tiré de ma lecture ou la synthèse de
l'état la révolution qui sont sur le
site militer de culture générale voire
pour lire cette biographie en entier
tous les liens sont dans la description
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser des
commentaires pour recevoir les dernières
idées de culture générale synthétisée
dans le format le plus clair possible
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la
newsletter en laissant votre adresse
email sur le site
je suis romain et vous étiez sur mille
disques culture générale n'oubliez pas
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête que vous pouvez être pragmatique
comme les lignes pour vous intéresser au
meilleur de la pensée
[Musique]